[موسيقى]
من بلد يسعى للديمقراطيه الى مواجهه الحرب
الاهليه من البحث عن الحريه والدوله
المدنيه الى البحث عن مكان امن يقي من نار
الحرب وشدتها هكذا اصبح حال السودانيين
فحتى في ظل الاجواء التي تلت الاطاحه
بالنظام عمر البشير كانت بذور الصراع
الحالي قد زرعت بالفعل في تربه البلاد
اخطاء مفصليه في تعامل واشنطن مع السودان
عددتها صحيفه واشنطن بوست ابرز هذه
الاخطاء تتمثل في فشل الولايات المتحده
والقوى الاجنبيه الاخرى في فرض عقوبات على
الجنرلين والحديث هنا عن قائد الجيش
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوه
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف
بحمل التين ذلك حينما اطاح معا بالحكومه
المدنيه سنه 2021
وبدلا من ذلك حاولت الحكومات الاجنبيه
اقناع الجنرلين المتنافسين بالاصلاحات
الديمقراطيه هنا طرح السؤال كيف يمكن جعل
من يحمل المال والبنادق يتخلى عن السلاح
خبراء اشاروا الى وجود عقبات امام الحكم
المدني منذ البدايه فحتى اذا كان المجتمع
الدولي خاصه الولايات المتحده فعلى كل شيء
بشكل صحيح كان من غير الواضح ما اذا كانت
الثوره ستنجح في المقابل كان واضحا ان
الجيش سيحتفظ بالسلطه فحكومه حمدك املت في
ان يتمكن السودان من تعزيز مكانته والقيام
بحزمه اصلاحات بدعم دولي خاصه من الولايات
المتحده لكن هذا لم يحدث ليعود هذا البلد
الى نقطه ما قبل الاطاحه بالبشير بل واصبح
على شفا حرب اهليه بلال البجداني العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات